we may be looking at war in the Middle
East John Kelly's nightmare is coming
true an Elizabeth Warren speaks to a
Native American group and it's pretty
funny I'll tell you all about a Ben
Shapiro show
so focus on ttis speaking in front of a
Native American group today sending some
serious smoke signals from her wigwam
about her future presidential run that
is not the mocking Native Americans by
the way that is me mocking Elizabeth
Warren's pretensions to be a Native
American she used that nonsense to
essentially become a professor at
Harvard Law School apparently and now
she's trying to use this Native American
group as a as a shield in order to
shield herself from accusations that
she's a liar about that Native American
heritage we'll get to all of those
things first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Birch gold so in
times of great uncertainty look at the
stock market right now you see how
volatile the stock market is that's
because sometimes the stock market gets
volatile and that's why you should have
some of your assets in precious metals
that is what Birch gold is there for
they have a long-standing track record
of continued success thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and you can contact
Birch gold group right now to request a
free information kit on physical
precious metals it's a comprehensive 16
page kit and it shows you how gold and
silver can protect your savings how you
can legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds into a precious metals
IRA if you choose to do so
get that no-cost no-obligation kit right
now at birchgold.com slash Benton that's
birchgold.com slash been again these are
the folks that I would trust there's a
reason why so many people trust them
with the precious metals investment ask
all your questions make sure that you're
comfortable with investing in precious
metals and then when you're ready talk
to my friends over birchgold.com / Ben
that is birchgold.com / band that / Ben
lets them know that we sent you
alrighty so I do want to get to all of
the issues in domestic politics a
shocking new poll that shows Republicans
now up in the generic ballot like
actually up in the generic ballot is
that's making a lot of headlines
Elizabeth Warren obviously making
headlines but I want to start today with
a story that people are overlooking and
that is we may have like a full-scale
war in the Middle East another one in
the very near future see when we decided
that we were gonna get rid of Isis that
was a very good thing but there's been
nothing to fill the gap and so what
you're ending up with now is essentially
six separate countries who are now
involving themselves in a Syrian war so
you've got Iran that's involved in Syria
you've got Israel that's in response
involved in Syria you've got the Syrian
government involved in Syria you've got
Russia involved in Syria you've got
Turkey involved in Syria there's a lot
of countries involved in a very small
space all of them fighting first
level of Supremacy of course the United
States is involved there at well as well
and all of this internation warfare
it could have serious external effects
so if you missed it over the last week
there was a major issue in which an
Israeli plane was shot down we talked
about this and Israeli plane was shot
down after Israel shot down a drone from
Syria it was an Iranian made drone and
Israel shot that down Israel flew in an
f-16 over Syrian airspace that was shot
down by a by a Syrian anti anti-aircraft
missile and then Israel said hey you're
gonna shoot down our planes here's what
we're gonna do to you
and they legitimately proceeded to
destroy half of the Syrian Air Force
well was on the ground because don't
screw with the Israeli military I think
is the is the main message there they
went in in an in an air raid and they
destroyed half the Syrian air force on
the ground one of the things this makes
clear by the way is just how much of a
lie it was when Barack Obama said there
was nothing we could do in Syria to stop
for example the the gassing of citizens
of that country Israel in legitimately
an hour destroyed half the syrian air
force half of it okay if the United
States had wanted to under President
Obama after the original Bashar Assad
chemical attack we could have grounded
his entire air force nearly immediately
but that's not the extent of the
conflict at that point the Syrians
basically backed off of Israel and said
okay we're not interested in doing this
right now but that's really a proxy war
Syria between Israel and Iran because
Iran is funneling supplies to Hezbollah
a terrorist group in Lebanon through
Syria and they're moving all of those
supplies directly through areas that
Israel has been hitting meanwhile
there's the Syrian proxy war heating up
between the United States and Russia so
on Tuesday Bloomberg News reported that
US and Kurdish forces in Syria had
killed 200 fighters including a bunch of
Russian so Russian Russia has a bunch of
contract mercenary soldiers on the
ground over there and the Russians were
fighting on the side of the embattled
leader Bashar al-assad they attacked a
military base in the de year Azure
region of Syria on February 7th now
there is no congressional authorization
for American forces to be in Syria okay
this is why we actually need as Rand
Paul says we need congressional
authorization if we're gonna be there
then we ought to have Congress authorize
it the American people ought to be clear
about what exactly our goals are there
is it to solidify is it to preserve the
status quo why exactly we're there why
our men and women in harm's
way what why are we spending our cash
there the Russians however actually
attacked a us run base essentially
there's a US force station with Syrian
democratic forces on a base and then and
those troops responded with artillery
fire and air strikes and 200-300
Russians were apparently killed in that
assault many of them were taken back to
Moscow and treated now the Russians are
denying that Russian forces were
involved in the attack which at least is
a moment is a good thing right that's a
good thing because if the Russians were
interested in some sort of open conflict
in Syria they would be claiming that
America had attacked Russian soldiers
but they want to pretend they're not
there in the first place so this remains
sort of a covert fight however major
Adrian Ron King Galloway is a
spokesperson for the US Department of
Defense
he said officials believed roughly a
hundred people were killed in the raid
though he said he couldn't speculate
about their nationality bloomberg
reported the number dead was closer to
200 the New York Times said dozens of
Russians were believed to be killed
CIA director Mike Pompeo this is Gordon
voxcom also refused to confirm specifics
when asked whether the US was
responsible for killing Russian contract
soldiers in Syria during the hearing on
Tuesday he said we have seen in multiple
instances foreign forces using
mercenaries in battles they'll begin to
approach the United States so again in
the last week we've seen Israel take out
half of the Syrian Air Force and we see
in the United States kill something like
a hundred Russian fighters apparently so
all of this is heating up in rather
rapid fashion and meanwhile on the
domestic political scene in Israel
Benjamin Netanyahu may be in some
trouble the Prime Minister of Israel has
now been indicted on a couple of count
on a couple of counts of bribery one of
those counts essentially suggests that
he was accepting gifts from wealthy
benefactors in returning for in return
for advancing their interests there's
another case that suggests that he was
trying to strike a deal that would have
given him positive coverage and you do
dejado note which is one of the major
newspapers in Israel in exchange for
hurting Israel hayom which is the Free
rival to idiot or not now when I find a
little more suspicious since the fact is
that Israel hayom is is very Pro
Netanyahu in the first place and it is
funded by Sheldon Adelson who's an ally
of bebés politically according to the
police in case 1,000 Netanyahu receives
champagne cigars jewelry and clothing by
demand and system and systematically
valued in about a million shekels which
is about 280 grand in American dollars
the gifts he received from the Israeli
American Hollywood producer Arlen MILCON
increased significantly once Netanyahu
was elected prime minister so there is a
case to be made against him in the media
case one of the problems in that case is
that one of the people testifying
against him is a political rival who is
a former news guy Yair Lapid he is now
in the opposition he wasn't attend
Yahoo's finance minister in the past and
he has been testifying against Netanyahu
bottom line is that in order for
Netanyahu to step down he's probably
gonna have to be convicted unclear
whether he actually would be convicted
in these cases and right now with Israel
under fire it's pretty unlikely that
Netanyahu is going to step down in the
middle of all this and what we're seeing
right now in other words is chaos across
the region and the Saudis the Jordanians
the Egyptians the Israelis are all
working hand in hand in order to try and
stop the impact of Iranian influence in
the region meanwhile Turkey is trying to
flex its muscles in places like Syria as
well as Kurdistan it is it is shocking
how the West has abdicated its
responsibility and part of that a huge
percentage that most of that is on the
Obama administration which went out of
its way to emboldened on which went out
of its way not to do anything with
Bashar Assad which went out of its way
to let Isis run roughshod throughout the
Middle East
at least until its latter days the Trump
administration has said a lot of the
right things on the Middle East but
they're not actually doing a lot on the
Middle East so whenever there's a an
uprising in Iran for example we say a
lot of stuff but it's not clear that
we're actually doing much of anything in
Syria right now we're doing a few things
but not enough that were actually
seriously involved and too much to say
that we're not involved at all at a
certain point we're gonna have to take a
harder position on what exactly we want
to see happen in Syria because otherwise
the chances of escalation here are
increasingly increasingly likely it's
increasingly likely that this will end
up spiraling out of control Israel hit
the Syrians the Syrians will hit Israel
Iran will be drawn in Israel go to war
with Iran a regional war like that would
look a lot like World War three because
Russia then might be drawn in on one
side with the United States on the other
all of that would be due to the
abomination of foreign policy that was
the Obama administration but if the
United States doesn't take some pre
clear active measures right now then
this thing could escalate out of control
pretty quickly and we would be dragged
into a situation that we really do not
want to be involved in in the first
place okay so I want to talk a little
bit about domestic politics in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over
at Skillshare so Skillshare is the best
way for you to increase your resume to
make your resume that much better right
it's it's a new year you want to make
sure that you are able to move up in the
world the best way to do that is by
increasing your skillset and that's what
skill share is for right skill share is
an online learning platform over 18,000
classes in design business technology
and more you can take classes in graphic
design social media marketing
illustration mobile photography you name
it they've got it so whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set start a side business or explore new
passion skills share is there for you
I've been taking the social media
marketing classes I know folks in the in
in this office of taking graphic design
classes I took a watercolors class which
relaxes me in the evening time skill
sure just has a ton of these courses
that are available for you so you're a
life well and learner that's why you
listen to this show Skillshare makes
that easy and they make it affordable as
well join the millions of students are
already learning on Skillshare today we
have a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents Skillshare is offering
my listeners two months of unlimited
access to 18,000 classes for just 99
cents to sign up go to Skillshare comm
slash am hero again Skillshare comm
slash imperial use that slash up hero so
you get that deal right again you'll get
two months of skills for just 99 cents
which is a fantastic deal you can see if
you like it Skillshare comm slash repair
we'll start that two months right now
Skillshare comm slash up hero let them
know that we sent you as well okay
meanwhile when the domestic political
scene elizabeth warren apparently is now
speaking out about how she is a native
americans she's speaking to the native
american native indian conference of
some such or other i'm not sure what
exactly is the National Congress of
American Indians that's what it was she
made a surprise appearance at the
National Congress of American Indians
and apparently she was just she was
incredibly great I mean she was she was
just full-on regalia she showed up with
the headdress she showed up with it with
the smoke and peace pipe the whole deal
and again whenever I say things like
this is not because I'm mocking Native
American cultures because I'm mocking
Elizabeth Warren for appropriating
Native American heritage okay so here's
what she said to the Native American
Conference quote by all accounts my
mother was a beauty I know Elizabeth
Warren by the way and she is one of the
more obnoxious humans on planet Earth
by all accounts my mother was a beauty
she was born in eastern Oklahoma on this
exact date
stay in February 14th 1912 she grew up
in the little town of Wetumpka the kind
of girl who'd sit for hours by herself
playing the piano and singing my daddy
fell head-over-heels in love with her
but my mother's family was part Native
American and my daddy's parents were
bitterly opposed to their relationship
so in 1932 when my mother was 19 and
daddy had just turned 20 they eloped
okay so she doesn't provide any evidence
by the way that she is of Native
American heritage at all like known like
zero evidence and then she says this is
my favorite line
I get why some people think there's hay
to be made here you won't find my family
members on any rolls and I'm not
enrolled in a tribe right so she's
openly admitting that she's not enrolled
in a tribe that you won't be able to
find any of her family members on the
Native American rolls remember the
record-keeping for Native American
heritage is extremely good right it is
very in-depth which is why you can have
situations where legitimately the
government will come and take somebody
who's 1/4 Native American out of their
foster home and bring them back to a
reservation because of how good the
rolls are right but this is the best
part she says quote our stories are
deeply woven into the fabric of who we
are the stories of immigrants and slaves
of explorers and refugees have shaped
and reshaped our country right up to the
present day for far too long your story
has been pushed aside to be trotted out
only in cartoons and commercials so I'm
here today to make a promise each time
someone brings up my family's story I'm
gonna use it to lift up the story of
your families in your communities and
that last line there as Alex Griswold
says at free beacon right that is called
using the Native American community as
your political human shield every time
someone calls for Foca haunt us every
time president Trump watches it and
calls her Pocahontas every time that
happens she's simply going to shift it
and say Native Americans are so
important Native American heritage is so
important nevermind the fact that we
call her focused because she's been
lying about her Native American heritage
I mean she's as Native American as Shawn
King as black apparently okay the idea
the Shawn King by the way his father was
white his mother was white on the birth
certificate he says that his mom had an
affair there's no evidence that any of
this is true the same thing is true of
Elizabeth Warren she suggests that she
was Native American there is no evidence
that at all that Elizabeth Warren is
Native American how much of a joke is
her Native American heritage it's such a
joke that Elizabeth Warren used as
evidence of her Native American heritage
the fact that you submitted a recipe to
a cookbook called I kid you not
powwow chow that was the name of the
cookbook and the recipe
she actually submitted was a recipe for
crab bisque and which it turns out she
she actually copied from a copy of Good
Housekeeping or something it turns out
that crab bisque is not actually a
Native American heritage thing because
crabs are not wandering across the
fruited Plains of Oklahoma which is
where she is from so she's a joke but
this is what Democrats are gonna do
they're gonna do the intersectionality
pyramid all the way to the bottom which
is just insane and so they're struggling
Democrats are struggling right now
there's a pull out right now shocking
poll from the political morning consult
survey right this is not a survey that
is biased toward Republicans and
Republican it shows generic polls right
now among registered voters thirty nine
percent said they would back the GOP
candidate in their district thirty-eight
percent say would they said they would
support a Democrat twenty three percent
are undecided so Democrats still have a
pretty solid advantage across a variety
of polls according to CNBC an average of
recent generic ballot shows Democrats
with about a seven point lead according
to Real Clear Politics but that was
thirteen points at the end of last year
so they followed at least six points and
there are a couple of outlier polls now
that show that the Republicans are
actually in the lead or even it so that
is a that is a big piece of news also
the political consult poll should
morning console poll that shows a forty
seven percent approval rating for
President Trump that's about as good as
it's gonna get for Trump Trump's never
gonna break fifty but forty seven
percent is a very solid approval rating
for President Trump so despite the
attempts to beat him down over the Rob
Porter situation or the bleep whole
country's remark it's as I said
everything is baked into the cake except
the evidence of how the economy is doing
that is not baked into the cake all of
the character stuff is baked into the
cake with Trump so for example there's a
story out today that Michael Kohn who is
Trump's lawyer did in fact pay stormy
Daniels a porn star one hundred and
thirty thousand dollars out of his own
pocket supposedly out of the goodness of
his heart that Cohen says quote neither
the Trump organization nor the Trump
campaign was a party to the transaction
with Miss Clifford that's a that's
stormy Daniels and I neither reimburse
me for my payment either directly or
indirectly
he said the payment to miss Clifford was
lawful and was not a campaign
contribution or a campaign expenditure
by anyone he was asked by the way why it
was that he had actually just signed a
six-figure check to a porn star with
whom he had not had personal relations
and he refused stands for those
questions it was just out of charity
he just likes porn stars that much and
feels
bad Fermi science random checks days
before the election the amount $130,000
of course that's a joke of course it's
ridiculous cohen is saying this in
response to a complaint one group filed
with the FEC regarding the payment right
he has not confirmed or denied anything
with regard to the payment itself but is
this hurting Trump anyway no of course
the stormy Daniel stuff happened two
weeks ago no one cared everybody
immediately brushed off the fact that
the presidents of the United States when
he was married and his wife had just
given birth was having an affair with a
porn star and then dropped 130 grand on
her days before the election to keep it
quiet or at least his lawyer did out of
the goodness of his heart man I gotta
get me one of those lawyers I got me one
of the wars who actually signs my gas
bill hey the lawyer who just says I love
my clients so much that out of the
goodness of my own heart I just pay
people off so that doesn't have any
impact on Trump and so Democrats are
struggling because the character attacks
aren't doing a lot of good for them
they're gonna continue to leverage them
of course but they're so ensconced in
the identity politics of what they do
that they're having some serious trouble
translating that into political victory
and so they have to sort of tell fibs
now their best angle of attack here
would be that President President Trump
doesn't care about you my president from
this is always the gap for Republicans
it's a gap for President Trump the
president Trump doesn't care about
people like you he's not really trying
to help people like you he's just trying
to help his corporate buddies right you
do the Bernie Sanders routine it is
shocking to hear that these words are
gonna come out of my mouth but Bernie
Sanders has the best angle of attack on
president Trump hey not Kamala Harris
not Cory Booker not all the people who
insist on being offended being offended
by Trump plays into his shtick if you
are offended by Trump Trump is one when
you say the Trump doesn't care about
people like you that is always the most
fruitful line of attack against
Republicans but Democrats don't seem to
care about that and so they're there
continuing on with this intersectional
nonsense so for example Senator Bob
Menendez from New Jersey he's going on
and on about how Trump doesn't care
about immigrants and we shouldn't use
the term chain migration again this is
intersectional nonsense now I find it
obscene the phrase chain migration it is
incredibly cruel to those whose
ancestors were bought to this country in
Chains in slavery it is a dehumanizing
element of what is in essence family
reunification which has been the core
of American immigration principle for
over a century the belief that when we
have families together that ultimately
they strengthen not only themselves and
help each other but they help build
communities and help build our nation
okay so this is absolutely idiotic
obviously the term chain migration has
nothing to do with slavery it was coined
in the mid 50's I believe it's been the
order since before then it has nothing
to do with slavery whatsoever the idea
is that chain migration like a daisy
chain like you're bringing people in in
a chain right not like you're actually
bringing them in in Chains but if
Democrats are trying this of course
they're going to fail to giant fail
they're trying also the angle that Trump
doesn't get that Trump is is in thrall
to Russia so there's a congressperson
named SWA well and he is a Democrat and
he is claiming that Trump is in thrall
to Russia good luck with that we just
killed 100 Russians on the battlefield
in Syria I think the simplest answer is
the correct one which is that he likes
the Russians he's told us that
throughout the campaign he said wouldn't
it be nice if we could be friends with
them and so when we need him for the
sake of our democracy to confront them
he's incapable so leadership starts at
the top okay so this of course is not
true at all the suggestion that
President Trump is in thrall to Russia
the American people are able to discern
the fact that Trump refuses to say the
Russian interfered in the election
because he feels that it is a blot on
his victory they're able to distinguish
that from the idea that he is Pro Russia
because obviously his policy has been
significantly more hawkish on Russia
than for example the Obama
administration which pledged flexibility
to Dmitry Medvedev and Vladimir Putin in
2012 and then gave them exactly that
flexibility and by the way the idea that
that Trump is somehow avoiding sanctions
because he loves Russia that's not even
true it's not even technically true
according to Noah Rothman who's no ally
of the administration over a commentary
magazine quote the Trump administration
was required by the countering America's
adversaries through sanctions Act to
give Congress both the classified and
unclassified list of Putin allies and
oligarchs that could be targeted for
potential sanctions and they did though
also required the administration to
provide a report detailing the impact of
sanctions on Russia's sovereign debt
which they did the WHA provided the
administration a 120 day grace period
for imposition of new sanctions on
unspecified targets if the president can
claim those targets have already
substantially reduced their business
activities in the russian defense and
intelligence sectors the State
Department declared the foreign
governments have abandoned plant or
announced purchases of several billions
and Russian defense acquisitions
therefore satisfying that requirement so
the idea that the Obama administration
rather has been deliberately avoiding
imposing sanctions is just not true
but the Democrats continue to try this
stuff out and this is why they continue
to lose this is why they have a serious
problem on their hands oh yeah in just a
second I want to talk about another
serious problem Democrats have and that
is full-on disdain for religion we'll
discuss that in just a second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at wink so I know that you were
getting over the new year I know that
you got all your drinking done in the
latter half of the of the 2017 December
and now you've rung yourself out well
folks it's time to relax a little bit
not only that the inner block big dinner
parties coming out tonight is
Valentine's Day but it's tonight is
Valentine's Eve what better then to get
a bottle of wine well winked calm can
make it happen for you hey wink wine
expert selected wines matched to your
taste personalized for you shipped right
to your door starting at just 13 bucks a
bottle there's nothing like coming home
to a box of delicious wink wine or to
the office where all of my employees are
drunk on wink wine on a regular basis
fill out that wink palate profile quiz
and answer simple questions that your
average store clerk wouldn't ask or
translate into a recommendation like how
do you take your coffee and do you like
blueberries and then white sari wink
sends wines curated to your taste the
more wines you rate the more
personalized or monthly selections and
every month there are new delicious
wines that are there for the sampling
shipping is covered so if you don't like
a bottle they send you they'll replace
it with a bottle that you will love no
questions asked no membership fees skip
any month cancel anytime discover
excellent wine today at Tri wink comm /
Ben that's tried winc comm so that's Ben
you get 20 bucks off your first shipment
that's gry winc comm / Ben for $20 off
again try winked comm / Ben that's t ry
winc comm / spending at $20 off folks
around the office love the wink wine and
also if you don't know anything about
wine you need to bring over a wine for
for a friend for a dinner then you can
take the palate profile quiz on their
behalf and get a wine that they will
love so that's pretty awesome check that
out try wyndcomm / Ben and get $20 off
as well as letting them know that we
sent you okay so when I talk about the
Democrats being at a complete disconnect
with the American people nowhere is this
more obvious than when it comes to
disdain for religion so yesterday on the
view Joy Behar who is just an
insufferable human being
I join twitch again joy have me on have
me on your show right we but I know that
tell the picture and sufferable have me
on your show but nonetheless the view
you know they I think they are probably
a little afraid to have me on that show
which I would be too if I were their
producers in any case Joy Behar goes
after Mike Pence yesterday in the most
disgusting terms about his religious
observance one thing to talk to Jesus
it's another thing when Jesus talks to
you exactly I'm not hearing voices okay
so just to be straight about how the
left views religious people if you say
that you heard the voice of God hey what
you mean usually okay let me just
explain on behalf of religious people
everywhere when you say you've got a
message from God you don't actually mean
that God sent you an email he's not
Bruce Almighty this is not God picks up
the phone and calls you it's not Joan of
Arc you're hearing actual godly voices
what you get is a feeling that perhaps
you're acting in consonants with your
meaning in the universe okay that you're
acting in consonance with what God wants
of you as you can decipher it in his
word hey that's what we mean as
religious people we don't mean that
we're sitting around and Jesus starts
talking to us say hi this is Jesus okay
you don't that's not what we mean my
panda has a southern accent either but
the idea that Mike Pence is sitting
around in the VP office waiting for
Jesus to give him orders is insipid I
will also point out that Joy Behar would
be the first person to say that men who
say they are women I do not have a
mental illness so if you're a man and
you say you're a woman you're not
mentally ill if you're a woman you say
you're a man you're not mentally ill but
if you're a religious person and you say
that you are trying to believe according
to the dictates of Jesus and that you
feel that you've gotten messages from
Christ in your life that this means that
you're a phone nut so it's that sort of
distain for religion that is driving
millions of people in the United States
away from people like Joy Behar it's not
just Joy Behar one of the people who's
been most irritating about the Olympics
is an ice skater named Adam rip on he's
gay which wouldn't make a difference
except he has made this the entirety of
his identity and when I say I mean like
he's made it his entire public persona
not that he's great ice skater which
apparently he is but that he is gay and
that he hates Mike Pence so he
apparently was ripping on pence for
being at the Olympics in the first place
suggesting that Mike Pence was for a gay
conversion therapy we talked about
couple of weeks ago this is not true
there's no evidence to support it
whatsoever doesn't matter he trotted
that out and then when pence said you
know what that's not true about me I'd
love to sit down with you rip on said
I'll never meet with you so obviously a
very tolerant dude well yesterday he
came out he says listen I don't want my
Olympic experience to be about my pun so
let's get this straight you punch Mike
Pence in the face rhetorically and then
you run screaming from the room and then
you say you don't want your Olympic
spirit experience to be about Mike Pence
because you've implied that religious
people all over the United States hate
gay folks and here's the atom rip on
doing the same routine I have no problem
talking about you know what I've said
because I stand by it
but I think right now the Olympics are
about Olympic competition and the
athletes involved and I talked you know
I talked to you about how I felt before
the games and you know it's brought a
lot of attention to you know in
questions to my other teammates and I
don't want to distract from their
Olympic experience and I don't want my
Olympic experience to be about Mike
Pence well it's a little late for that
it's a little late for that you ripped
Mike Pence has a religious bigot and
then you come out and you say well I
don't want my Olympic experience to be
like that maybe you should have thought
about that before you decided to rip
Mike Pence as a religious bigot in by
extension all of the people in America
who are evangelical Christians as
religious bigots it's not just that okay
the culture war is that the left launch
brought them Trump yeah when I say this
is how you got Trump this is how you got
Trump got a bunch of people in America
who feel like they are constantly being
set upon and torn to shreds for simply
being religious people or simply being
white right in some cases based on the
intersectional politics have left or
simply for being in a Midwestern state
are there all these groups that the left
has seen as great oppressors in American
life white folks males religious people
and then the left sets upon those people
and those people say well you know what
I'm gonna vote for that guy who at least
doesn't crap on me all the time but this
is what Democratic Party does this is
what people on the Left you on a routine
basis you want to reach out to folks you
want to win elections then maybe you
ought to stop trying to alienate them
with most with incredibly radical
language and maybe you ought to stop
with with the fawning media coverage for
social issues that are at best deeply
controversial so CNN for example has a
piece today about this tragic case where
parents want custody of their 17 year
old
their 17 year old girl okay listen to
how CNN covers this here's the story
okay I'll tell you the story it's a 17
year old girl she thinks she's a boy
she's transgender and so she wants
hormone treatment and she went and she
got some doctors who say that you should
have hormone treatment and then she
tried to have custody handed over to the
grandparents the parents of listen
you're gonna be 18 when you're 18 we
can't do anything to stop people and
you're 17 not on our watch on our watch
you are not going to have surgeries and
mutilate your genitals you're not gonna
have surgeries and mutilate your breasts
we're not going to allow you to have
hormone treatment and mutilate your body
that's not something that we're gonna
allow you to do because we don't think
that that is the best treatment we don't
think that the scientific evidence is
there
okay the scientific on this stuff
evidence on this is at best mixed it is
at best mixed their studies that suggest
that suicidality the the suicide attempt
rate goes down from people who attempt
transgender surgery there's also some
evidence that suggests that after a
certain period of time the suicide rate
goes back up so the the evidence is is
just not it's not perfect in any
direction this is not a cure-all by any
stretch of the imagination but here is
how this is going down CNN writes quote
an Ohio Court will decide the fate of a
transgender teen who is in what the
judge described as a gut wrenching
situation the seventeen-year-old
identifies the boy neither he nor his
family can be named according to court
instructions so notice already how CNN
starts calling this girl heat right this
is a biological woman and CNN is already
calling this girl he in order to bias
the case because if the parents won't
acknowledge it CNN well the teens
parents want court authority to stop
their child from getting the treatment
in therapy that was recommended by his
medical team and what it characterizes a
possible life-or-death situation what
makes it a life-or-death situation
apparently the teen is suicidal and
they're suggesting that the cure for the
suicidality is hormone treatment and/or
genital disfigurement that is what the
this team of medical experts suggest
well maybe there's another team of
medical experts that suggests
differently and the parents could
consult a variety of medical experts but
now courts in the united states are
going to talk about this is gonna be the
next step you don't talk about cultural
wars this is the culture war the next
step is gonna be you have a
five-year-old child and your child says
that she is a he and you say sweetheart
no you're not you're gonna outgrow this
you know we'll go and we'll talk to
somebody about this but you are eight
you're a girl and we're gonna try and
get through this together in the best
most healthy possible way courts will be
sent in by the left to take your child
away from you this is the next step it's
already happening in Canada under Bill
c16 and this is what they're going to do
according to CNN the team was
hospitalized in 2016 he had been
diagnosed with depression and anxiety
disorder and gender dysphoria according
to court records this is this is the key
by the way this is the reason why the AP
a's evidence list reclassification of
gender dysphoria gender identity
disorder to gender dysphoria actually
matters so gender identity disorder
suggests that gender I did that when you
are disordered right when you are a male
who believe
you're a female that this is a disorder
and it associated with that disorder are
depression and upset right and that the
in that but it is a disorder that must
be treated head-on gender dysphoria they
say that's perfectly normal it's
perfectly normal if you're a man who
believes you're a woman the only thing
that's problematic is if it crosses over
with depression right there's no actual
delusion you're actually a man a woman's
body but it's only a problem if you're
depressed so the idea is if you treat
the depression then you will be
alleviating the gender dysphoria
the evidence for this is no it does not
exist the idea that if you alleviate all
of the all of the life forces that the
suicide rate goes down to normal non
disordered levels is just not true right
there's no evidence that the the suicide
attempt rate in the transgender
community post surgery or if everybody
calls you by your preferred pronoun goes
down to the normal rate of a normal man
or a normal woman who does not believe
they're a member of the opposite sex
it doesn't matter the court is probably
gonna try and take away this kid and
give the kids to the grandparents who
apparently are gonna go along with the
treatment and they're saying that the
the apparently the the attorney for the
family says the parents maintained they
love their child and said the child's
mother said the child has nothing to
fear from her and she wants to have a
relationship with her child she also
acknowledged that if the parents are
granted custody they want the child to
continue to live with the maternal
grandparent to avoid parenting their
child but because they believe that the
current living arrangements is in the
teens best interest but they say this
kid is not capable of making a
life-altering decision right now the
court is gonna disagree and they're
gonna say that if they call the kid by
the kids normal name if they say that
the she is a she then the kid is gonna
commit suicide that means that it's on
the parents this is a very dangerous
precedent that's being said it's the
reason why we're in the middle of a
brutal culture war and it is there are
political aspects to this that are
really that are really a problem there
are a serious problem okay in just a
second I'm gonna give you the update on
the Rob Porter fallout because it looks
like it's getting worse not better for
the White House first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker ok so you lost your phone you
lost your wallet you lost your keys
because the day ending and why and we
all lose those things every day but no
longer do you have to worry about this
this is what tracker is for so I lose my
keys and now I lose my keys I grab my
phone and I can just use the tracker app
and I can find my keys if I if I lose my
phone I have the tracker bluetooth on my
keychain and I just hit it and my phone
starts beating it doesn't matter if the
ringers off doesn't matter
if I've turned the volume all the way
down it will still beep - it will still
be Paul the way through and that means
that you can find your phone if it's
buried under a couch cushion or in my
child's car seat as the case may be
this ritual of looking for your keys
your wallet your phone and no longer has
to be a thing because of track or pixel
so you'll never have to worry about
losing things again it's the lightest
blue true that tracking device on the
market you put the tracker on whatever
you tend to lose keys wallet purse it is
small enough to fit anywhere when you
misplace an item that has a tracker
pixel attached you can use your
smartphone in a 90 decibel or it will
help you find it in seconds it even has
powerful LED lights so you can find
anything even in the dark you can locate
your item if it's miles away things
every tracker user is part of the
largest crowd locate network in the
world as well save 20% off your order
when you go to the track our comm /ban
that's without track our comm /ban you
get 20% off again the track our comm /
pen when you use that / penny get 20%
off the tracker plus you're letting them
know that we set you as well so the
track our comm / Ben alright so I want
to talk about the fallout from the Rob
Porter situation but for that you're
gonna have to go over to the website and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
uh subscriptions daily wire comm gets
the rest of the show live gets the rest
of the Andrew Clavin show live gets the
rest of the awful terrible no good very
bad Michael Noel's show live by the way
later today Michael Mills will be doing
a Valentine's Day episode with all of
your special letters in the mailbag
so if you feel like ruining your
Valentine's Day that way then go for it
today February 14th 5:00 p.m. Eastern
Michael will be literally be waiting for
your questions in our next episode of
the conversation his pathetic police for
attention will be on Facebook YouTube
the daily wire website free for free to
watch only subscribers can join the
website and ask the questions to ask
questions as subscriber log into our
website over at daily wire comm head
over to the conversation page and watch
the live stream and after that start
typing into the daily wired chat box
Michael will answer live questions as
they come in for an entire hour so
subscribe and get those questions
answered by Michael today 5 p.m. Eastern
2 p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
if you want all of those things Plus
this the fantastic never before never
before
compared I lost words if you want a
great mom the leftist here's how to
wreck old tumblr this is the thing okay
you got it with the annual subscription
99 bucks a year
cheaper than the monthly so go and check
that out right now or check us out later
iTunes SoundCloud YouTube subscribe
Lewis
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so in some bad news for the White House
trey gowdy the House Oversight Committee
chair or at least member the House
Oversight Committee he said that the
House Oversight Committee kicked off an
investigation into the Trump
administration's employment of Rob
Porter the White House staff secretary
who resigned last week and what White
House officials knew about domestic
abuse allegations against him so Gowdy
said you can call it official you can
call it unofficial I'm gonna direct
questions to the FBI that I expect them
to answer and if they don't answer them
then I go and I'm going to expect a
really good reason why senior White
House officials have been struggling to
come up with an answer for exactly how
they allowed Rob Porter to get so high
up in the administration despite all of
the allegations about spousal abuse he
has two separate ex-wives who allege
spousal abuse Paul Ryan said the White
House has to work to improve their
vetting system I don't know how exactly
they'll do that I will leave that to
them but chairman Gowdy is doing his
proper job on oversight and yes he did
give us a heads-up one of the big
problems yesterday is that the FBI
director Chris Rea came out and he said
that the timeline that was presented by
the White House with regard to Rob
Porter was just not true that basically
the White House had known for months
maybe years about Rob Porter's
allegations they did nothing about it
get into the content of what was briefed
what what what I can tell you is that
the FBI submitted a partial report on
the investigation in question in March
and then a completed background
investigation in late July that is soon
thereafter we received requests for
follow-up inquiry and we did the
follow-up and provided that information
in November and that we administrative
leak losed
the file in January and then earlier
this month we received some additional
information and we passed that on as
well so it is pretty obvious that the
FBI was continuously updating the the
White House and the White House did
nothing about it this is all on John
Kelly there have been serious rumors
inside and outside the White House that
John Kelly is on his way out that the
general who was supposed to have brought
word to the White House has instead
exacerbated the disorder particularly
with regard to this Rob Porter
there was talk yesterday that Gary cone
as Breitbart call him the globalist Gary
Cohen would take over as Trump's chief
of staff if that were the case there was
even some rumors going around that he
might bring back the mooch which would
be the greatest thing on planet Earth
please bring back the moves we need a
season two I mean come on
cameo is the most beloved guest star in
season two of Trump we're now in season
three of Trump bring back the moon come
on so if the moon comes back then things
will become wildly more entertaining and
you can expect that that we will get
just I mean I want to entertainment bang
for my buck if we're gonna go through
all this at least better be entertaining
the White House tried to suggest that
the FBI director was not contradicting
them on their story this of course is
not really true here's Sarah Huckabee
Sanders trying to make that case
yesterday look we explained the process
extensively last week the White House
personnel security office staffed by
career officials received information
last year and what they considered to be
the final background investigation
report in November but they had not made
a final recommendation for adjudication
to the White House because the process
was still ongoing when Rob Porter
resigned in the view of personnel
security office the FBI's July report
required significant additional
investigatory field work before
personnel Security office could begin to
evaluate the information for
adjudication as director Ray said
information was still coming to the
White House personnel security office in
February now the truth is that the chief
of staff's job is essentially to keep
the president in line and unfortunately
it's become a sort of babysitting job to
a certain extent making sure that Trump
is not talked to by some of the worst
people keeping bad influences away from
the Oval Office and Kelly had been doing
a good job of that until the whole Rob
Porter scandal happen you do have to ask
yourself why it was the Kelly stuck by
him maybe it's because we all as human
beings have an individual tendency to
pretend that folks that we know aren't
really bad people like think of the
people in your life and think of some of
the things that they've done are all of
them universally good people I know some
people in my life who if I if I heard
about their stories and I heard about
them second hand I think wow that guy's
a jerk
that guy that guy seems like a bad guy
but you make provisions for people that
you know in your personal life the
problem is when you're working on a
governmental level you don't have the
ability to do that you don't have the
capacity for forgiveness particularly in
a case like this where you really
shouldn't
a capacity for forgiveness in any case
when the guy isn't asking for
forgiveness we're parents where it's
apparent that he was fibbing about
knocking around women that's pretty bad
so here's how it's breaking down at the
White House according to Vanity Fair
apparently in recent days Trump has
floated a couple of names White House
budget director Mick Mulvaney and
longtime friend Tom barek a real estate
developer for White House chief of staff
that's just what we need is somebody
with no experience in government coming
in and trying to run the White House
Mulvaney would at least would know what
he's doing I'm not sure the beric would
barek has already said that he's not in
particularly interested there are
apparently other factions that are
looking to to bring in a new chief of
staff
apparently Jordan Ivanka Trump wants to
bring in Gary Cohn so last night three
Republicans said that Trump had offered
the job to Kohn but then Trump told Sean
Hannity that he'd not chosen Cohn and
that's because Cohn is not a career
Republican right Cohen is actually kind
of a Democrat apparently Sean Hannity
was pushing somebody else Hannity was
pushing maybe House Leader Kevin
McCarthy perhaps perhaps Wayne Berman
who I've never even heard of Wayne
Berman I believe that he is a senior
adviser to Blackstone so the idea is
that he has ties to to Capitol Hill so
there was there was talk about him being
close with Mitch McConnell there are a
bunch of people who are close to Bannon
who have been trying to push for Mark
meadows as chief of staff
you know Meadows is chief of staff
certainly make the the administration
more conservative I'm not sure that it
would do I'm not sure that it would
balance a lot of the competing interests
inside the White House McCarthy
apparently is sort of interested in
today he refused to suggest that he
would not take the job if you were
offered it the Republican has said that
McCarthy is going around saying the
president needs better messaging which
is obviously true so a little bit of
chaos inside the White House apparently
the president made sure last week that
Kelly had heard that he called Reince
Priebus for advice which was a way to
alienate Kelly and maybe get Kelly to
quit so all of this is a mess the mess
comes from the top this in this case the
mess comes from Kelly but the fact that
Trump governs by chaos is not a is not a
good thing right Kelly really should do
this he should just come out you should
apologize he should have come clean from
the beginning he should have said we
made a mistake
I gave the benefit of the doubt to
somebody who'd been vouched for by a lot
of top figures that was in the state
we should never have done it oops if you
had done that all this would have blown
it over in a week
now instead we are in week two week
three of all of this that is not good
stuff at all right the administration is
gonna have to do something to cure the
perception that they're serious chaos
breaking out inside the administration a
meanwhile by the way there are new
estimates on Trump's military parade
which is just another distraction
apparently Mick Mulvaney says it would
cost between 10 million dollars and 30
million dollars now I understand why I'm
not into the idea of a military parade
and civilian streets that's not
celebrating you know in actual military
victory the last military parade we had
in the United States was after the Gulf
War but I don't understand why the left
is eons higher military parade they seem
to like North Korean military parades an
awful lot so I'm not sure why they're so
opposed to an American military parade
so this is so-so that apparently is
still on the table now
does any of this actually affect Trump
in the long run the answer is no as I
suggested before now the Democrats have
been unable to capitalize on Trump's
unpopularity again he's hitting his
high-water point now and that's that's
47% which is not super-high is so they
in order for the Democrats to capitalize
on his unpopularity they're gonna have
to connect his supposedly passion for
the American people with their passion
for the American people but that would
force them to abandon their
intersectionality they actually have to
say listen we like Americans more than
Trump does that's a hard call when
you're sending the entire media out to
talk about the glories of North Korea
and the stupidity of Mike Pence is just
not a brilliant move now if the economy
tanks could Republicans really pay sure
is it possible the polls are overstated
that's possible too
yesterday there was another there's
another Republican seat that flipped I
think it was in Florida another
Republican Senate seat state Senate seat
that's 36 legislative seats that
Republicans have lost since Trump took
office and that doesn't have the makings
of a wave yet but it certainly should be
a disquieting note for a lot of members
of the administration who seem to
suggest that nothing terrible is going
on everything's going to be ok we just
don't know at this point but Democrats
are struggling for a message there also
by the way borrowing Bill Clinton so
according to Politico Democrats are
looking to embrace the me2 moment and
rally women's push back on Trump in the
midterms good luck with that they tried
it with Hillary and they don't want Bill
Clinton anywhere near it they're scared
of Bill Clinton now so they're making
the same mistake they always made they
suggesting that Hillary Clinton was a
better candidate than Bill Clinton they
cannot they they're just addicted to the
victim politics they are addicted to the
identity politics it is going to destroy
the Democratic Party it's really a giant
failure on their part Bill Clinton is
still still tremendously much more
popular than Hillary Clinton ever was
right there trying to take advantage of
the me2 movement by suggesting that the
Trump administration is mean to women
and John Kelly is mean to women and
Trump is mean to women in all this
that's not how you get people out to the
polls you get people out to the polls by
suggesting that the other side is not
just morally bad but effectively bad and
Democrats haven't done that in any in
any real serious way so this is none of
this none of this is good by the way
when the White House's story on Porter
continues to just fall apart late late
yesterday there was a report that even
after there were the news of the Rob
Porter giving his ex-wife a black eye
had come out that he had sat down for an
off-the-record meeting with for
reporters brokered by the White House
and the reporters president for the
meeting which included the New York
Times Maggie Haberman Washington Post
Josh Dow Z Axios is Jonathan Swan and
Wall Street Journal's Michael bender
press reporter to explain the picture of
his wife with the black eye and he told
and he told them but he had told his
colleagues that on vacation in Venice
the two had quarreled over a Venetian
glass vase and that his then-wife had
accidentally bruised her eye in the
course of that altercation which happens
all the time the vase just reaches out
and touches somebody in the eye so that
said that's always a big win for them
the administration ought to get past
this but Democrats are not gonna be able
to take advantage if they keep doing the
the identity politics routine okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so let's begin with
with a thing that I like I've been
playing for my daughter she loves
classical music she will only listen to
classical music because I have moulded
her and I've shaped her and now she is
it elitist which is exactly what I want
her to be when it comes to her musical
tastes I'm one of the pieces that she
really likes is the the young person's
guys at the orchestra by Benjamin
Britten this piece is the reason it's
called the young person's guides the
orchestra is basically it goes through
all of the instruments in the orchestra
and they each play individually
throughout the course of the piece and
so she's gotten really good at naming
all of the various pieces in the
orchestra she knows the difference
between an oboe and bassoon which is
pretty sophisticated for a just turned
four-year-old in any case here is
Benjamin Britten's young person's guys
orchestra it's really great builds to a
tremendous conclusion it's a really fun
piece so go check that out it's a great
way to educate your kids about the
instruments in the orchestra which at
least if my daughter's an indicator they
really enjoy okay other things that are
like so Bill Murray who is not one of my
favorite actors I said something I think
that is exactly right and it is a note
for the Democrats he was talking about
identity politics and here's what he had
to say make everyone laugh she's not
thinking about being political she's
thinking about what resonates and what
has common to all of us I think that
that's harder and harder to do because
people are trying to come you know
trying to win their point of view as
opposed to to saying what if I spoke to
everyone my friend who's a great comedy
writer Jim Downey
he's accused of being a right wing
writer a comedy writer if there is such
a thing sermon he says no no I just
think the way that the Democrats hang on
thing is poor the way they try to pick
out little pieces of a population and
where we represent the Hispanics we
represent it LGBT or something and
they're not speaking to everyone at once
so it's almost a meaning to say I'm
choosing you because you're a splinter
group or you're a certain minority group
there's almost a resentment that somehow
you're separated again by a politician
you know that you're my people you're
I'm in control of you and I represent
you instead of thinking that each of
each citizen has a right to be respected
as a citizen for someone under the laws
of the country this is exactly right
Bill Murray is not a rabid right winger
Bill Murray is not a Republican Bill
Murray is a Democrat right the idea that
Bill Murray is is suggesting to demo
perhaps that they ought to abandon
identity politics they don't wish to
alienate the vast majority of the
country is of course exactly right now
well Democrats listen to him of course
not because they're incompetent speaking
of which time for some things I hate all
righty so things I hate today Gregg
Popovich has become so obnoxious this is
the coach of the San Antonio Spurs and
suddenly the great arbiter of American
morality here is what he had to say
yesterday about America and how racist
America is which is incredible
considering that all of the players who
play for him who are black are making
millions and millions and millions of
dollars for playing a game here's Greg
Popovich nonetheless talking about what
a terrible place America is well I think
it's pretty obvious the leave is made up
there's a lot of black guys so to honor
that and understand it is pretty
simplistic how would you ignore that but
more importantly you know we live in a
racist country that hasn't figured it
out yet and it's always important to
bring attention to it even if it hangers
some people the point is that you have
to keep it in front of everybody's nose
they understand it still hadn't been
taken care of and we have a lot of work
to do so if this is something that Gregg
Popovich actually believes then he said
he doesn't understand the nature of
America he doesn't understand the nature
of Americans or shelling out millions of
dollars a year to go watch a bunch of
black guys play basketball in Popovich's
words that's not because they are a
bunch of racists okay the reason that
you know that is because for a long time
the NBA was not integrated there for
many years when racism was much more
prevalent in the country was a rarity
for there actually to be black
basketball players they had all four up
the famous college basketball culture
University of Kentucky would not allow
black players on his team
that obviously is not the case and the
NBA is a growing concern if you were to
buy a team in any sport right now your
best investment would probably be in the
NBA because Americans are not afraid of
black folks Americans are very much
ensconced in in black culture and in
parts of culture that that are
influenced by by powerful black people I
think that's a good thing because I
think the black folks contribute an
enormous amount to the culture and I
think white folks contribute enormous
amount to the culture but the fact that
Popovich suggests that America is a
deeply racist place immediately after
saying the entire NBA is black and these
folks
and millions of dollars there's a pretty
strong disconnect there okay so quick
Bible note since it is indeed a
Wednesday we haven't done Bible study in
a little while so I wanted to point this
out with regard to pre-emptive war so if
you're talking about war in the Middle
East and the possibility of pre-emptive
war in Middle East is real striking Iran
for example or the United States taking
out Russian mercenaries there there's
this idea that that a lot of religious
people are sort of uncomfortable with
pre-emptive war that is that that's
somewhat silly in Exodus 22:1
it specifically talks about the fact
that pre-emptive war is is necessary and
pre-emptive killing can sometimes be
necessary if you can discern the
person's rationale for attacking you so
here's what it says says if while
breaking in a thief is discovered he is
struck and dies it is as if he has no
blood now meaning that the
responsibility for his own death is on
his head and so Rashi who's the most
famous of Jewish commentators he
comments on this and he says this
signifies it is not considered murder it
is though the thief was considered dead
from the start here the Torah teaches
you the lesson if someone comes to kill
him
you kid to kill you you kill him first
and this thief has come to kill you
because he knows that no one can hold
himself back and remain silent when he
sees people taking his money therefore
the thief has come with the
acknowledgement that if the owner of the
property were to stand up against him
the owner the owner would kill the thief
meaning if someone breaks into your
house at night with the clear intent to
steal stuff from you and harm you then
you have the ability to kill them the
the Torah actually makes a distinction
in Exodus between if you were robbed
during the day and and robbed during the
night but the next the very next verse
says if the Sun shone upon him then he
has blood he shall surely pay if he has
no money he shall be sold for a step so
in other words you can't kill him you
have to capture him if he comes during
the day why because Rashi says there's
and this is nothing but a metaphor
meaning if the matter is clear to you
that the thief is peaceably disposed
toward you similar to the Sun which
represents peace in the world so it is
obvious that he has not come to kill you
so in other words if it's obvious that
someone is coming to kill you you should
kill them first if it's not then you
should try to find a better way
obviously this is true so for all the
people who think that the Bible is a
pacifist document the answer is no all
right we will be back here tomorrow with
all of the updates we'll see you that
ben shapiro ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing